Más allá de que una persona desarrolle
cáncer una atención temprana adecuada
podría reducir considerablemente el
número de muertes Cuál es la real
importancia de la atención primaria
Bueno muy buenas tardes Muchas gracias
por la invitación en este espacio tan
importante en esta fecha que todos
conmemoramos en la lucha contra esta
enfermedad
entre el cáncer puede ser curables te
detecta tempranamente y es una patología
que es susceptible de prevenirse y de
detectarse definitivamente hasta el 30%
de las patologías pueden ser curadas y
las detectamos muy tempranamente y otras
tantas podremos detectarlas en unas
fases en donde el tratamiento surta su
efecto y mejore la supervivencia de la
población bueno en América Latina Cuál
es la realidad de esta enfermedad es
decir cuáles son los tipos más comunes y
en Qué grupos poblacionales se presentan
con más frecuencia
bueno en América Latina en el año 2020
se presentaron cerca de millón y medio
de casos nuevos y murieron
aproximadamente 700,000 personas en solo
América Latina Tenemos cáncer que son
muchísimo más frecuentes como son el
cáncer de próstata el cáncer de mama el
cáncer de colon y recto el cáncer de
pulmón y el cáncer gástrico son los
cáncer que presentan pues una mayor
incidencia y el de mayor mortalidad es
el cáncer de pulmón hay otros tipos de
cáncer asociados a infecciones Como por
ejemplo el cáncer de cuello uterino que
ha atendido a disminuir pero existen
otros que están empeorando como los que
te acabo de nombrar entonces esa es la
situación de de nuestros países de
América Latina y el Caribe si pudiéramos
determinar una clave cuál sería para
mejorar la atención al cáncer en la
región
bueno tenemos varios aspectos que son
relevantes uno la prevención hacer
control del riesgo para que la
enfermedad Pues reduzca el número de
casos número dos hacer la detección
temprana para lograr que cada vez mayor
esta mayor tipo de cáncer se
diagnostican en estadios primarios para
mejorar la supervivencia y la
posibilidad de de tratamiento y de cura
exitosa Pero también es importante
mejorar el acceso al tratamiento
oportuno que no se presenten tantas
barreras de acceso para que los
pacientes diagnosticados inicien pronto
un tratamiento en menos de 30 días deben
iniciar su tratamiento para lograr Pues
que haya una mayor probabilidad de
curación Bueno al hablar de una
enfermedad Como el cáncer también se
discute una algo así como una
responsabilidad compartida así como las
autoridades tienen una responsabilidad
los pacientes y las personas también
Cómo se puede convencer al público en
general de que accedan o que se hagan
los exámenes diagnósticos así no haya
signos clave de que la enfermedad ya
esté presente
sí es esto es muy importante el cáncer
es una enfermedad que nos toca a todos
no solo a los servicios de salud y no
solo a los pacientes esto nos
corresponde a todos es importante vencer
el miedo al cáncer Nosotros hemos
llamado esta fobia al cáncer y ahí
población que a veces dice prefiero no
hacerme las pruebas porque de pronto me
encuentran cáncer qué tal tenga cáncer
el llamado a la población es que deben
acceder a todas las pruebas de
tamización y detección temprana sin
importar que aún no tengan síntomas es
mejor que no tengan síntomas porque
cuando una patología ya síntomas el
estadio probablemente es mayor como lo
dije el inicio el cáncer puede ser
curable si se detecta tiempo y la
probabilidad de sobrevidas mucho mayor
si se detectan fases tempranas el
llamado a la población es primero
Hagamos una prevención es decir cuidemos
nuestros estilos de vida
está demostrado que factores de riesgo
como El cigarrillo el alcohol el
sobrepeso el sedentarismo Y pues la mala
alimentación aumenta en el riesgo de
algunos tipos de cáncer entonces
tengamos unos estilos de vida saludable
y dos así estamos a nuestras pruebas de
tamización o de detección temprana
idealmente de manera periódica y no
esperar a que tengamos síntomas y tres
si llegamos a tener síntomas acudamos al
médico y no tengamos miedo porque esta
enfermedad puede ser tratada